what
are the seven deadly sins what do they
have to do with christianity how
essential how crucial they are to uh the
religion and what's the most challenging
in our modern day yeah to name them uh
pride
envy anger
sloth avarice gluttony and lust are the
seven deadly sins
or quote capital sin sometimes uh from
couplet they're the head sins from which
things tend to flow
the most fundamental is pride
uh
probably most people today if you talk
about like vice or you talk about you
know deadly sin they would think about
lust but the classical authors including
dante who
does this pictorially
there that's the least of the deadly
sense is lust because it's the one
that's most sort of
dependent upon the body and it's and
it's passions and so on
the most important is pride pride is the
deadliest of deadly sins and it's very
simple to see why
pride is the augustine calls it incredu
sensei i'm caved in around myself
like a black hole right to get into the
scientific
but the black hole to me is a great
symbol you know that
it it's so heavy that draws everything
including light nothing can escape from
it
see that's the center that's the we're
all sinners uh we're like black holes
that we draw everything into ourselves
as a sinner and you know i'll confess
i'm a sinner um the temptation is okay
this is the bishop baron moment and i'm
gonna i'm drawing you now into my you
know world and so on
what that does is it kills us off and it
make it it darkens life
and it makes it small and and heavy and
awful right
it's like
but see compared to the to the
contrasting thing is when you're lost in
a moment
you're not concerned about the
impression i'm making you're not
concerned about drawing the world into
yourself you're not concerned about this
monkey on my back that's always telling
me you know look good and sound right
but you're you're lost in something
you're just you're just talking you know
to a friend and the two of you together
are discovering something true or or
beautiful or you're lost in a movie or
you're lost in a book those are the best
moments in life those are the best
because of the least prideful moments
right
that's when i the light comes out
i i become radiant because i i'm
overcoming this tendency to fall in on
myself um
dante is so good because the way he
pictures um
satan in divine comedy and you know he's
at the center of the earth so like a
black hole that way he's at the center
of gravity he's at the heaviest place
and he there's not fire where he is but
ice which is much much better image that
you're frozen in place and you're stuck
and he's got wings
right and they used to be angel wings
because he's an angel but now they're
like bat wings for dante and they're
flapping
and all they're doing is making the
world around him colder because he's ice
he's stuck in his own iciness and then
he's he's beating his wings over the ice
making everyone else colder it's a great
image
and then he has this is cool too he has
three faces uh satan
because he's a simulacrum of the trinity
so every sinner thinks he's god so i
pretend i'm god so he's got the three
faces and from all six eyes he weeps
also from all three mouths he's chewing
a sinner he's got cassius
brutus and judas in the three miles you
know the three traitors
but i thought it it's just a great image
of all of us sinners is we're stuck
it's heavy it's cold
we're chewing on our past resentments
we're weeping in our sadness and we're
making the world around us colder it's
beautiful it's a great so that's pride
see that's an image of pride because
satan that's his great sin pride which
is why he needed michael right mikael
who's like god so that the great
challenge to him which we need all the
time is someone to say wait a minute
wait a minute you're not god but the
minute we say i'm god
black hole i now cave in on myself i
suck everything into myself and i turn
into dante satan
so that's a great image that's pride
that's the most fundamental
that's the uber capital sin it's all the
other ones flow from that in a way so in
general empathy humility compassion love
thy neighbor always the way to fight
this the sin of pride right which is why
the masters tend to say this was bernard
saint bernard was asked what are the
three most important virtues and he said
humilitas humilitas and humilities
because it's the opposite of pride yeah
so
but you know they're bringing aquinas in
again uh because we think i'm humility
i'm i'm no good that's not what it means
at all it means what i was describing
before
when you're you're just lost in
something you're just lost in it um my
image i live out in santa barbara and uh
i like to walk on the beach out there
and there's a section of the beach where
they let the dogs you know run free
without leashes
and uh
when you see a dog and
he's well cared for and his master's
right there and and the master's
throwing the tennis ball and the surf
and the dog goes galloping out into the
surf and he gets it with a big smile and
comes running back
that's that's humility that's an image
of heaven because he's just lost in that
moment he doesn't care about impressing
anybody don't care about uh what people
think of him he's just lost in it that's
it that's heaven right
and those moments in our life when we
when we get that it's a little hint of
of paradise but but the trouble is most
of us live frankly most of the time in
various
levels of hell you know and we're and
we're dealing with these deadly sins
like envy flows from pride because if
i'm prideful i'm a black hole i'm in
curvature sensei i'm collapsed in what
am i really going to be concerned about
that guy's got more attention than i am
that guy's richer than i am
that that lady she's got a bigger
reputation than i do and why why don't i
have that right so envy is a very close
daughter of pride
um
anger flows from
why do i get angry the dog isn't getting
angry on the beach when he's running
after the tennis ball but i get angry
all the time sputter with anger when
things aren't going my way and and
you're insulting me and you're not doing
what i want and i'm being hurt my
reputation so anger flows from pride you
know
all of them do all the deadly sins do
so
you said i'm a sinner
so we're all sinners yeah
um
you mentioned satan where's the so
there's
heaven and hell
there's god and satan
where's the line
between what it means to be good
and uh
not good enough
or i i hesitate to use the word sort of
uh evil but
maybe
overwhelmingly sinful
where's the line between hell and heaven
think of them as limit concepts maybe
they're like heuristic devices yes so
heaven would name this ultimate
friendship with god so think of the dog
on the beach who is just he's fallen in
love with his environment with his
master with the serf he's just lost in
it right he's forgotten himself he's
transcended himself and is now lost in
the wonder of the beauty of that place
now
imagine the limit of that is the is the
friendship with god that we talked about
that i become the friend of god i become
so
forgetful of myself so lost in the
beauty and truth and goodness of god
that i'm
i've i found beatitude right i found
joy the beatific vision we call it uh
that's the limit case that's that's what
we're tending that's where god wants us
to go
think of hell as the limit case in the
opposite direction that's curvature
sensei that's the black hole and we're
all sinners meaning we're somewhere on
that spectrum you know we
we have good days and bad days and we
have good moments and bad moments and i
can be drawn toward
sin
what's god's purpose and christianity's
reading is to bring us out of that you
know now where did he go he went all the
way into it to get us out of it it's
like pulling the sock back out socks
inside out you have to go all the way in
and pull it back out and so
god had to go all the way down
you know and there there's the
trajectory of the incarnation
though he was in the form of god and
this is saint paul jesus did not deem
equality with god a thing to be grasped
at but rather emptied himself and took
the form of a slave being born the
likeness of men but then
he was known to be of human estate
and he accepted even death death on a
cross and so paul imagines that the
incarnation is this downward journey
in order to get all of us right all of
us who were stuck
were stuck in our sin
and so again paul says he became sin on
the cross it's a really really powerful
idea he wasn't a sinner because then
he'd need to be saved too he's not a
sinner but he entered into our
dysfunction in order to pull us back out
of it
you